[Musica]
in verità mi sarebbe piaciuto che il
titolo fosse vincere tanto e perdere
poco per una buona educazione allo sport
perché ho sempre avuto un pessimo
rapporto con con la sconfitta anzi io
odio perdere persino quando da bambino
mi capitava di giocare in spiaggia
biglia con gli amici
non sopportavo l'idea di perdere
rosicavo così tanto che prima di tutto
non lo facevo vedere agli amici e poi il
giorno dopo
andavo in spiaggia prima che arrivassero
a loro e mi mettevo a giocare mi
allenavo perché volevo vincere e questo
anche quando sono diventato poi un
calciatore professionista e qualche
partita andava storta o qualche
risultato negativo qualche errore banale
commesso o se c'era qualcosa che volevo
migliorare allora ecco che l'allenamento
diventava un momento sacro per me è
diventava un momento dove cercare di
migliorarmi per cui capitava che andassi
prima agli allenamenti o mi fermassi al
termine chiedendo magari l'aiuto
all'allenatore in seconda
l'allenamento è un momento importante
momento di grande crescita
e se è vero che le vittorie aiutano a
vincere vincere aiuta a vincere perché
la vittoria ti dà grande autostima ti dà
grande consapevolezza dei tuoi mezzi ti
dà grande forza è anche vero però che
alcune vittorie possono fare più male di
molte sconfitte
e come disse un grande allenatore che ho
avuto in nazionale arrigo sacchi
sarebbe bello che
le squadre i giocatori continuassero a
crescere ea migliorare nei momenti di
euforia dei momenti di vittoria ma in
quei momenti invece succede che si
perdono di vista le piccole cose i
particolari c'è un po la tendenza
magari a fare una corsa in meno per il
compagno
c'è un po la tendenza ad ascoltare meno
quello che l'allenatore dice il compagno
dice perché ti senti forte no ti senti
bello ti senti onnipotente e quando meno
te lo aspetti boom arriva la mazzata
arriva da sconfitta che ti fa riflettere
ti fa tornare con i piedi per terra ti
fa tornare umile ed ecco che a questo
punto cosa succede dentro di noi perché
i momenti difficili
i momenti bui capitano capitano a tutti
nello sport come nella vita ma
importante il modo in cui tu gli
affronti che fa la differenza il modo in
cui tu decidi di lasciarsi alle spalle
il modo in cui tu decidi di andare oltre
se penso per esempio quando mi capitava
da calciatore momenti di sconfitta ci si
ritrovava il giorno dopo negli
spogliatoi con i musi lunghi e ho
imparato abbiamo imparato che la prima
cosa da fare è cercare di eliminare gli
alibi perché è troppo facile scaricare
la responsabilità su compagni
arbitri fortuna o sfortuna ci sono
variabili nello sport che non puoi
controllare e devi accettare ma ci sono
invece variabili che tu puoi
direttamente controllare e l'allenamento
è uno di quelle variabili
perché se ti alleni con determinazione
con passione con voglia di migliorarti
di sbagliare unito il tuo talento è più
facile che tu possa raggiungere un
obiettivo positivo mi piace pensare al
fatto che dietro
ad una grande vittoria ci possa essere
una grande sconfitta un momento di
grande cambiamento un momento di svolta
se penso alla juve di oggi sembra tutto
facile
sette scudetti vinti consecutivi coppa
italia ma come non tornare indietro non
dobbiamo dimenticare da dove siamo
partiti dal 2006 calciopoli
retrocessione in serie b l'orgoglio e la
voglia di una società di una squadra di
ritornare ai vertici vinto il campionato
di serie b terzi in serie a secondo in
serie a
primi no settimi settimi boom una
sconfitta inaspettata un risultato
inaspettato che porta cambiamenti ai
vertici della società cambiamenti
ovviamente nella squadra e cambio
d'allenatore
ma quel momento la voglia di rinascere
la voglia di ripartire
diventa fondamentale
ed ecco che ancora una volta diventa
importante non il fatto di evitare le
sconfitte quello chiaro bisogna provarci
ma il modo in cui poi tutti trovi ad
affrontare quando capitano se penso alla
mia storia personale
c'è un flash c'è un momento che mi viene
in mente se devo pensare ad un momento
di svolta quando giocavo nel varese in
serie c
a vent'anni andammo a giocare una
partita a carpi ci saranno stati forse
mille spettatori c'era nebbia
la partita finì 0 0 un tiro in porta noi
forse un tiro in porta
gli avversari una partita tristissima
bruttissima quando finisce la partita
uscendo dagli esco dagli spogliatoi vado
incontro il mio procuratore che aveva
notato
la partita e mi dice ma che intenzioni
hai
perché sergio scusa ma tu hai voglia di
provare andare a giocare in serie a
sì perché perché se continua a giocare
così
resterei a vita un giocatore di serie c
perché perché sei un giocatore anonimo
se un giocatore piatto ti stai adeguando
al ritmo della categoria ti stai
adeguando i tuoi compagni ma se tu hai
ambizione di fare qualcosa di diverso e
vuoi andare a giocare in serie a devi
darti una sveglia
potete immaginare io ero fitto bello
tranquillo quindi quelle parole quelle
frasi sono state veramente forti ci sono
però tanti personaggi non solo sportivi
che hanno tratto grandi insegnamento
dalle loro sconfitte dai loro fallimenti
mi viene da pensare per esempio a steve
jobs che racconta come il periodo
successivo al licenziamento da apple sia
stato per lui il momento più creativo
della sua vita oppure se penso ad un
tetto un atleta un grande atleta come
michael jordan che racconta come le
tante partite perse i tanti tiri
sbagliati i tanti fallimenti siano stati
il segreto del suo successo
vorrei raccontarvi anche un episodio
della germania è un episodio importante
per chi fa settore giovanile la germania
nel 2004 venne clamorosamente eliminata
ai campionati europei
questa clamorosa eliminazione
inaspettata soprattutto fece cambiare
completamente trash ticamente il modo di
pensare di ragionare il calcio in
germania la federazione decise in
accordo con le società e le società tra
di loro decisero di mettere i giovani
calciatori
al centro del progetto
tecnico ci fu grande sinergia fra tutte
le componenti ea distanza di dieci anni
nel 2014
la germania vince il campionato del
mondo nel 2017 la germania vince la
confederations cup e contemporaneamente
vince il campionato europeo under 21 ma
la cosa pazzesca
dal mio punto di vista è che 4 5
giocatori che vinsero la confederations
cup avrebbero potuto e dovuto giocare il
campionato europeo under under 21 ma le
scelte coraggiose della federazione
degli uomini all'interno della
federazione degli allenatori furono
quelle di anteporre la crescita dei
giocatori il progetto di crescita dei
giocatori perché fare la confederations
cup era sicuramente un'esperienza più
importante nel loro percorso di crescita
rispetto al risultato finale
e questo ancora una volta torniamo a
quello che ho detto prima quando
capitano i momenti difficili momenti bui
la differenza la fa il modo in cui tu
gli affronti in modo in cui tu vai oltre
personalmente vi ho detto all'inizio che
ho sempre avuto un pessimo rapporto con
la sconfitta è anche con l'errore e vi
posso assicurare che questo è stato
molto faticoso
nella mia vita nella mia carriera perché
non perché avrei voluto sbagliare di più
ma avrei voluto giustificarmi un po di
più per tornarmi un po di più l'errore e
oggi che sono un dirigente del settore
giovanile della juventus
chiedo e pretendo che i miei ragazzi i
nostri ragazzi sbaglino soprattutto in
allenamento perché devono avere il
coraggio di osare e rischiare di giocare
tirando fuori tutto quello che hanno
dentro perché il talento se c'è paura
non emerge non povere emergere e noi
dobbiamo essere bravi a non giudicarli
ma a dargli la possibilità di trovare le
soluzioni pensate che a distanza di
tanti anni sono ancora in contatto con
con i ragazzi che con me hanno fatto
settore giovanile del milan perché quel
periodo è un periodo è stato un periodo
ricco di emozioni e le sconfitte le
vittorie i momenti belli i momenti
brutti superati insieme ci hanno aiutato
a essere oggi più forti e ed è quello
che oggi chiedo ai miei ragazzi chiedo
di vivere questo periodo con grande
passione con grande determinazione
avendo il coraggio di sbagliare di osare
e di viverlo con tutto quello che hanno
dentro
vorrei citare una frase di nelson
mandela
per me è molto significativa io non
perdo mai certe volte vinco altre imparo
ed ecco che questo deve essere il
messaggio che ci deve dare lo sport
perché lo sport deve insegnare a vincere
con rispetto rispetto per se stessi
rispetto per gli altri perché deve
insegnare a far tirare fuori tutto il
potenziale che noi abbiamo dentro
attraverso il sacrificio attraverso il
coraggio di sbagliare attraverso la
determinazione ma deve anche insegnarci
a reagire alle sconfitte perché gli
errori le imperfezioni i piccoli o
grandi fallimenti non devono essere un
limite alla nostra prestazione ma un
grande alleato
grazie